people are finally starting to wake up
to something crucial
something i've been talking about for
years when republicans wage a war
against so-called cancel culture when
the right
decries businesses making decisions
about what's best for them
because of backlash from the public what
they are criticizing what they are
fighting against
is the very free market that they have
been defending
almost to the death i mean it's almost a
religion for these people the free
market
and they've been doing it really since
the reaganization of republican politics
in the 1980s this
um a prayer at the altar of free market
capitalism and this
exposes a deeper truth about the
american right wing
not only are they short on policy as
we've talked about many times
and not only do they simply play on
values
even the values they play on are only
relevant
up to the point at which it becomes
inconvenient what i mean by that is
they talk about the power and the
efficiency
of markets to guide economies and
cultures and countries
they say markets are much smarter than
government officials or politicians
but then as we saw this week when dr
seuss's publisher decides
here's six books out of a whole bunch
here's six books
that we're going to stop publishing
because some of the content doesn't
really fit into
uh what are considered acceptable uh
sort of social norms or
portrayals of minorities right now
that's a
free market decision made by a
for-profit company
because they looked at public opinion
and they said
let's make the decision that's best for
our bottom line and republicans
instantly throw their supposed values
out the window
and spend three days and probably it'll
be more
talking about the travesty of dr
seuss's so-called cancellation so not
only do they abandon
their supposed free market principles as
soon as they don't like the outcome
dictated by the market they also
weaponize it
into the very outraged porn that allows
them
to make money by covering this stuff on
tv
it's not new that they abandon their
values when it's inconvenient this is
just the latest way
think back when democrats are in the
white house
all they talk about is debt and deficit
and the importance of balancing the
budget
george w bush comes into office among
other things give tax cuts to the rich
and goes to war
a really expensive war with the wrong
country and in so doing
explodes the deficit and they say
nothing
but then donald trump comes into office
and then cuts taxes for
the rich blows up the deficit again
and they say nothing at all and yet not
only
do they abandon their values when it's
not convenient
they want to inject government into it
when a market guides
a decision that they don't like and look
at the trajectory
on this dr seuss thing we are for free
markets and keeping government
out this means you would imagine
businesses do what they want as long as
it's not illegal and the government
stays out of it
dr seuss enterprises which made more
than 30 million dollars last year
decides here's six books we will not
continue to publish
they're not canceling dr seuss they're
not burning
books they're saying here's six books we
will allow to go out of print but if you
want to buy a used copy you can go ahead
and all of a sudden the sovereignty of
business to do what it wants to do
goes out the window but not only that
republicans including people like jim
jordan the congressman demand
congressional hearings on cancel culture
why is any of this the business of the
federal government
where is rand paul as a principled
libertarian
to say there is nothing for the federal
government to do related to this
we should have no role here whatsoever
hearings
no way in hell these are private
businesses making decisions however they
want to make them
they're not breaking any law so quite
simply the government should have no
involvement whatsoever
the market as they like to say should be
allowed
to work its magic if this decision by
soos enterprises
is wrong then the market will take care
of it period
if more people are mad about this
decision
than the number that like it and they
want to
exercise their ability to participate in
free market
capitalism they can say well i'm not
going to buy any dr seuss books anymore
i'll go buy whatever i don't even know
and then the market will take care of it
this is their view
which they now are abandoning but the
truth is
that this has nothing to do with their
stated principles
what they mean by the free market is a
market that pushes society
and culture and institutions in the way
they want it to be pushed
they don't like the way that the market
forces are leaning right now
in the direction of sensitivity to
racial and ethnic issues they don't like
it
and that's fundamentally what this is
all about and this makes you know
i've said before this movement that only
wants to talk about
principles principles are a great place
to start
but when you only talk about principles
you enter what's called a philosophical
black hole
and the really difficult work is
figuring out real world situations this
is
so so one part of the principles
movement
that's bogus is that they very quickly
abandon their stated principles when the
outcome isn't what they want
but this is the other aspect of it that
when you only talk about principles
you end up with situations like this
they don't like it that's what this is
all about
and then this is also extraordinarily
profitable for many
and that's what i want to talk about
next the more we learn
about various diets around the world the
more we realize
that some of the healthiest diets where
folks are living the healthiest and the
longest
are heavily plant-based and one of our
sponsors
just egg is a great place to start just
egg
cooks and tastes just like real eggs
but it's made from plants it has less
saturated fat
no cholesterol packed with protein i've
been cooking with just
egg at home and you can use it
in so many different ways just like
traditional eggs
omelettes scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread
one of my favorite dishes pad thai
it also is better for the planet
generating 93 percent
fewer carbon emissions and 98 percent
less
water than conventional eggs you can
find just egg at lots of grocery stores
whole foods kroger amazon prime now
and instacart check it out just egg
really is a great product from a company
with a great
mission and i'm really glad that they're
a sponsor of the show